john gruden the coach of the raiders
potentially may be longing for the days
when his biggest problem was trying to
deal with antonio brown
i don't know what the league is going to
do about this but
but and let me let me just
peel back the curtain a little bit chris
and i don't know that i've even told you
this
someone sent me the clip early yesterday
morning
of john gruden on the chris collinsworth
podcast featuring richard sherman
and the interaction between gruden and
sherman and chris
tried to save john right before the two
started talking he tried to warn him
about what he could and couldn't say to
a guy who's not yet a free agent even
though as you'll see
the coach and the players seem to think
he is currently a free agent
and i was like look look i got enough
issues right now
i got enough john gruden's already mad
at me for enough things like pointing
out if it was any other coach right now
uh he'd have been at least mentioned for
possibly being fired based upon his
performance the last three years so i
it's like you know what i'm not
listening serenity now i'm not messing
with this and then during the show
yesterday a general manager
texted me that what gruden said to
sherman
is the most blatant case of tampering
he'd ever seen
so with that so then i decided i got to
deal with it so we got to deal with it
we got to bring it to you
here is chris collinsworth john gruden
richard sherman pay particular attention
to the things said
by gruden to sherman here it is
that's fine i've been punished very very
harshly but
uh richard sherman if you are a free
agent which there is a rumor you are
we are looking for an alpha presence in
our secondary
somebody that can play this hawk three
press technique with the read step uh
if you're available and interested maybe
you and i can get together at some point
off here
yeah there's a conversation to be had
for sure um you know i am i'm free and
available these days
um fortunately and unfortunately
okay the laughter doesn't matter the
attitude doesn't matter
the words are what matters if you look
at the nfl's anti-tampering policy this
is a textbook case this is a stronger
than textbook case because gruden speaks
to sherman
as if sherman is currently available
he's
not currently available he remains
under contract to the san francisco
49ers
until 401 pm eastern on march 17.
period now there's a 48-hour window
before that
immediately before that where gruden
could negotiate directly with sherman
because sherman represents himself
but it's not march 15 yet it's february
4. you cannot have that conversation
privately publicly seriously
joking and i wish we'd had the full clip
there because chris does
try in kind of a a jovial way
to to tell john hey you know don't you
know we know there's tampering rules
and john just like the hell with it i
don't care i don't care that there's
tampering rules i've been fine before
i'll be fine again
let's go let's have this conversation i
just was stunned by this and chris
here's the bottom line
if the nfl doesn't do something about
this and i you know oh you're being the
whole monitor no if you got rules on the
books you're not going to enforce why
the hell have them
if they don't do something about this
one there is no tampering rule
well i would like the first thing that i
think of and you know
pete demolitis put this on my radar
yesterday would be like the
you know the andy reid uh the draft what
was that when he talked to was that
macklin
jeremy macklin right he spoke to jeremy
macklin right
a guy that andy reed had drafted and
coached right
when macklin became a free agent five
years ago or so
during that 48 hour window when it's
permissible to negotiate with the agent
technically you can't talk to the player
you can talk to the agent can't talk to
the player
turns out reid talked to the player
right and they whacked the chiefs
for that so that third round pick that's
for that right
that's what i want that's what i want to
say that's what i wanted to say
right i mean so that that you know and
and is what we saw there in that clip is
every bit as egregious as
is that what andy reid did with jeremy
macklin and everything like that so
that's where it will be interesting to
see
what the nfl does as far as this concern
listen i don't know
why gruden did it i can tell you this
like gruden loves football
he is a true fan he loves these players
he loves the game and he really does get
infatuated with players
like a fan like he really does there's
no doubt it's like
it's different than your normal head
coach he really would be like i wouldn't
be shocked if he's got a tape of richard
sherman
and is just like man you know and he
shows his other corners and like look at
it he wears his uniform look how awesome
he does this and that
that's the kind of coach he is so he
does let love
letting players know how much he loves
him that's where i'll stick up for him
now the rest of it i can't really stick
up for him i mean i don't know
what you're doing like yeah you're
playing with fire
you're playing with fire and yeah the
league's been harsh on you but
that was because you were playing with
fire then and pouring gasoline on it too
so yeah i would think it's almost like
daring the nfl
to mess with him here that's what's kind
of you know odd about it in like this
al davis raiders type of way which i
think is
kind of cool in a lot of ways but um
yeah he's gonna get his butt in trouble
and gonna probably uh have to hear from
the league at some point
the original punishment in the macklin
case and i think it may have been
softened a bit on appeal but they still
got
whacked third round pick in the 2016
draft sixth round pick in the 2017 draft
350 000 in fines 250 for the chiefs
75 large for big red and 25
000 for john dorsey so this is not
something that the nfl trifles with
when the nfl decides that it's going to
enforce the rule see this is the thing
and we don't have enough time for me to
go
fully into my rant about how
inconsistent the nfl can be but that's
the core problem here there are
tampering violations all the time
we know that right the nfl looks the
other way most of the time because you
can't enforce it in every case
but when you're either motivated to send
a message like they were with the chiefs
or it is blatant and it is in plain
sight and it is there i asked the nfl
about it yesterday declined comment
we'll see what they do by way of action
but when it plays out that blatantly
how can you not take action it's like
the injury report they never do anything
about it right until it's blatant like
when
ben roethlisberger's elbow goes out
without contact
and he clearly had a pre-existing elbow
injury and he wasn't on the injury
report
they whacked the steelers for that
they're gonna have to do something here
chris or the tampering rule
is meaningless and the hypocrisy will be
obvious i
agreed all everything you said there and
where i'll go into it too
is like if you let this slide then
i then i i don't want to hear it the
next time a player
you know what if the roles were reversed
what if the roles were reversed
and you know it was some like one of
john gruden's players
right where hey i want this guy back he
can be a free agent march 17th like
you're saying
we want them back we're just trying to
figure it out right now
now that that player that he likes is on
a podcast or doing something like that
what if he's oh now another coach is on
there hey coach i'm free and available
you know i think you're looking for a
corner in your defense right now
like are they going to start letting
stuff like that slide that's that's
where i think it gets real
dicey and uh be interesting to see how
the league does
does this whole thing again this is the
most blatant example of tampering i've
seen
it's in broad daylight it isn't even in
the shadows it's out in the open
and i guess it makes it less shocking
than if you hear that it happened like
if we heard this it happened if we had
rumors about that conversation
i'd be like oh my gosh i can't believe
that happened there's no rumors
it's reality it happened on camera so i
i there's no way the nfl can avoid doing
anything about this and if they don't
then the anti-tampering rules moving
forward mean
absolutely nothing hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports